mi nombre es mother misrachi señores
señoras hoy he venido a hablarles sobre
la impotencia masculina en la juventud
de hoy en día
no mentira
en
de hecho el título de mis pizzi no no
tengo nada que mostrarles porque
realmente todo lo que tengo que decirles
usted ya lo han visto así que enfoquen
se realmente en mí quiero que sepan que
hoy decidí no maquillarme así que puntos
por orgullo disque es natural
cuando ustedes usan gmail hacen la mano
el que no mira para atrás la mayoría del
sol a mano cuando usted paga por gmail
ok casi nadie
solía ser que
cuando tú querías un software tú tienes
que comprarlo
en los tiempos de antes incluso incluso
hoy pero comprabas office 120 dólares
instaladas office en una máquina y
usabas todo el world todo el excel que
tú quisieras ilimitado
eso cambió recientemente en los últimos
15 años la compañía tecnología
evolucionaron a buscar unos métodos de
monetización más creativos ok en donde
básicamente han optado por crecer rápido
reduciendo las barreras de entrada
mayormente hablando de dinero los
software son gratis como gmail casi
ninguno de nosotros pagamos
pero el costo de software gratis tiene
realmente un precio y eso es lo que he
venido a hablar hoy
en silicon valley hay un dicho muy común
que dice si tú no estás pagando por el
producto
tú eres el producto
qué significa eso tú no estás pagando
con dólares estás pagando con tu
información
el problema es que nosotros no sabemos
cuál es el valor de nuestra información
y por qué no es un sistema totalmente
transparente no sabemos cuánto esta
información es la que usamos para pagar
para que tengan una idea el costo que
ustedes están ahorrando gmail
y me genera 3500 dólares al año de cada
una de sus cuentas ahora piensa ustedes
si gmail
les cobraría ustedes 200 dólares al año
usted lo pagarían probablemente no
y mucho menos pagarían los 3500
entonces para entender el costo de
gratis vamos a ver específicamente el
mundo de guineo aunque por qué email y
me fue creado hace más de 30 años pero
no fue creado para el uso que le damos
hoy hoy en día y me hoy es uno de los
medios de comunicación más populares del
mundo más necesario incluso
más de 4 millones de personas mil
millones se dice español
más de 4 mil millones de personas al día
mandan 300.000 millones de email al día
el problema es que estos emails para que
entienda estos emails carecen de la
privacidad de
de una conversación normal no son
seguros la seguridad no es sexy pero es
necesaria lo que es como el seguro
nuestro carro no queremos hasta que lo
necesitamos
y para que entiendan como inseguro email
es bueno más explicar cómo funciona
whatsapp que si es seguro cuando tú le
mandas un mensaje de whatsapp
ese mensaje es trancado es cifrado con
una llave única que solo la tienes tú y
la persona a la cual le está enviando el
mensaje así que tú le manda el mensaje
alguien intercepta mágicamente el
mensaje no puede leerlo porque no tiene
la llave
ese no es el caso con dinero tú mandas
un niño es lo equivalente a poner un
file
un word en un acb y tras pasarlo por ahí
quien sea pueden leerlo quien sea y los
emails pasan por miles y miles de
servidores antes de llegar a su
destinatario
para tutorías a mí qué me importa o sea
yo no tengo nada que esconder
el problema es que email
no debería de ser inseguro por el hecho
de que email como por funcionalidad se
asume ser privado nosotros no hacemos y
medio como hacemos twitter no es público
si bien es cierto tú recibes emails de
netflix sugiriendo de que películas ver
en base a lo que ya has visto o sea que
ya no sabe cuáles son tus preferencias
de películas tú recibes confirmaciones
de compras de amazon okay diversa ve que
tienes una saludable adicción a seriales
y encima gmail reside en tu email tú
recibes tu reserva al hotel de ámbito de
este fin de semana o sea que sabe que tú
no vas a estar en panamá y
específicamente que vas a estar en
chiriquí y bueno digamos que chinos
además de ti que lo que tú crees que tú
sabes de ti mismo en esta versión
experimento de cada uno se describía
cómo se ven cómo se ven en sí mismos y
luego el sistema de inteligencia
artificial de google les decía cómo cómo
era esa persona y resulta que
el sistema artificial boost conocía a la
persona mejor de lo que las personas se
conocía así mismo el peligro en esto es
que toda esa información de gmail es
consolidada ok
y se manda para la vaca lechera de
google cual es la vaca lechera seguro
nosotros conocemos muchos productos de
google android google chrome el
navegador
google maps si nos fuéramos perdidos
incluso weiss
cómo se llama
you tube que no de youtube y google
search ok y básicamente todos estos
servicios no le hacen un real agudo
personas más populares resulta que todo
estos servicios existen para consolidar
información crear un perfil tuyo como
persona y dársela a la vaca lechera que
es google arts el 2018 google hizo 136
mil millones de dólares en ingresos y 95
por ciento de ellos vinieron de google
light pero tú nunca escuchas al google
hablar de google porque el mundo quiere
que tú sepas que esta es la forma que
funciona
ahora es normal es normal que un negocio
en internet funciona a base de
propagandas twitter
instagram todos funcionan a base de
propagandas ok eso lo sabemos pero como
pues tenemos un comentario estúpido en
twitter que sabemos que lo estamos
conscientemente de que va a ser público
igual con instagram es muy diferente sin
embargo el momento de tu público
comparte un email una conversación
privada por email
y luego te enteras que esa cooperación
no es privada
porque resulta que lo que tú ves en tu
celular es un reflejo de lo que está en
un servidor que no te pertenece en la
nube que ellos te quieren mostrar dentro
un correo
dice que no está leído pero resulta que
google ya está sugiriendo hasta las
respuestas de cómo responde el alzheimer
ellos lento ahora repito puede que no te
importe porque dice yo no tengo nada que
esconder
y eso es argumento es entendible pero no
es válido no válido porque
porque la privacidad en el 2019
es uno de los recursos yo diría estar
recursos
más violados de nuestro vivir nosotros
no pensamos la privacidad porque lo
tomamos como pasito como respirar que
empiece a respirar deja lo que hace
naturalmente pero con la popularidad de
las comunicaciones digitales nuestra
privacidad se vuelve cada vez más
inexistente el problema es que no lo
sentimos
yo lo personal yo viví una circunstancia
es que
le llevaron a reconocer como mi
privacidad era violada y los precios que
yo pagué por ello
erwin oren dice el siguiente argumento
quiero que me consideren esto
sí decir que no te importa tu privacidad
porque no tienes nada que esconder es
como decir que no te importa
la libre expresión porque no tiene nada
que decir
el hecho de que no tengas nada que
esconder no simple que no tienes nada
que proteger nuestras conversaciones son
privadas
y el hecho que son privadas es lo que
nos permite conversar o expresarnos de
forma natural
por ejemplo esto yo practicaba este
speech 20 meses me dieron nuevas
prácticas pero se siente diferente
decirlo en frente de todo un público
que decirlo en privado
y cuando tú mandas un correo y comienza
a considerar que eso está siendo
escuchado comienza a cambiar la forma en
la que la que hablas y como tu data se
vuelve un método de pago
realmente reconsiderar si vale la pena
gratis
me voy a aburrir más con este tema pero
yo quiero que está esta noche cuando yo
termine este speech en 7 segundos lo más
consideran lo siguiente usted van a
abrir su celular y normalmente van a
usar un app que no están pagando y no
más recuerden sé que si usted no están
pagando por el producto ustedes son el
producto
ahora no me aplauden porque yo no vine
aquí entretenerlos más bien a
informarles de algo que sí en mi
material muchas gracias y buenas noches
[Aplausos]